what what will mission control be
getting fed back to it and
what are we thomas going to be able to
to see in here
i understand there's quite a delay yeah
there's a
11 minutes 22 seconds it takes for
signals to come back from
uh mars at the moment it's that far away
uh so it is a matter of
crossing your fingers and by the time we
actually get the first signals that uh
it has entered the atmosphere um
with luck it should already be on on the
planet's surface
uh that's the kind of delay um that
we're talking about but once it does
enter the atmosphere it'll be traveling
at uh 12 and a half thousand miles an
hour
it'll rotate put its heat shield down
towards the
the direction of travel because that is
going to heat up to
1 300 degrees celsius
uh at uh well just 80 seconds after it
enters that's the the peak temperature
and then once it gets to about seven
miles about the planet's surface
should be traveling around a thousand
miles an hour that's when it deploys its
supersonic parachute
which apparently was built by a company
in tibetan the fabric there is able to
withstand these extraordinary high
temperatures
and at that that will then float slowly
down to
a speed of about 200 miles an hour and
that's when
it deploys its rocket-powered jet pack
and and that takes the the final
uh descent down to the surface okay well
we're just looking uh
very closely there into the eyes of some
of the personnel
of mission control in pasadena as we've
been hearing there's not much they can
do
now and it's less than 30 seconds now
until perseverance enters as i say the
outer reaches of mars atmosphere before
it
then descends as thomas was saying very
very rapidly indeed
in those immense temperatures and
hopefully lands
safely on the planet's surface let's uh
listen to mission control
we have confirmation of entry interface
presidents is currently going 5.3
kilometers per second
at an altitude of about 120 kilometers
from the surface of mars
the fifth is now waiting until it begins
feeling the atmosphere slow it down
once there is enough atmosphere it will
start controlling its
path to the landing target
navigation is also confirming that we
can see a little bit of that slow down
of the atmosphere on
the perseverance entry capsule
our current velocity is about 5.36
kilometers per second and an altitude of
about 67
kilometers from the surface we are
probably seeing mro plasma blackout at
this point
the vehicle should be doing its turns
right now hameron has lost luck
president
we have indications that perseverance is
now performing bank reversals
in the atmosphere these are the steps in
order
to control its distance to
the landing target press events has just
passed through
the point of maximum deceleration and
has indicated
that it felt approximately 10
earth g's of deceleration amarillo has
locked again
yes yes yes yes
we saw a small outage of the
uhf telemetry from mars reconnaissance
orbiter during that peak heating phase
likely caused by the plasma black cap
perseverance is still continuing to
perform bank reversals
in the atmosphere to control its
distance to the landing target
perseverance is going about one
kilometers per second
at an altitude of about 16 kilometers
from the surface of mars
we have entered heading alignment which
means
perseverance is no longer trying to
control the distance to mars but ends
to the target on mars but instead is
flying
straight to the target
parachute
well uh tense moments tense minutes
there at
nasa mission control in pasadena in
california
tension as well i can see amongst my
guests and i'd like you to translate
some of
what we've been hearing there from
mission control libby jackson at one
point uh
perseverance rover was traveling at 5.36
kilometers
a second i heard and enduring
10 earth gs of deceleration
my goodness me even i can understand i
mean that stress is enormous
it's huge it has to go from 12 and a
half thousand miles an hour
down to you know a gentle landing the
bit that was making my ears perk up
there was when
we were hearing that mro the mars
reconnaissance orbiter
had lost um contact and looks like
things are going well
that was expected as you uh plunge into
the atmosphere
um everything's going to get a plasma
around the spacecraft the same thing
happens when athletes return
back to earth in the international space
station so it's expected but
any loss of contact with the spacecraft
makes your heart uh jump a little bit
and it was really lovely to hear that
they regained contact and
everything seems still to be going well
we're now into the part where the
parachutes have opened and of course all
of this
has happened we're now just looking into
the past waiting for telemetry
that's right well let's listen into
mission control that
confirming that uh parachutes have
opened it's getting closer
yes yes yes first
now has radar lock on the ground current
velocity is about 100 meters per second
6.6 kilometers of the surface
perseverance is continuing to descend on
the parachute we are coming
up on the initialization of terrain
relative navigation
and subsequently the priming of the
landing engines our current velocity
is about 90 meters per second at an
altitude
of 4.2 kilometers
almost there we have confirmation that
the lander vision system has produced a
valid solution
and part of terrain relative navigation
we have timing of the landing engines
current velocity is 83 meters per second
at about 2.6 kilometers from the surface
of mars
we have confirmation that the back shell
has separated
we are currently performing the divert
maneuver current velocity is about 75
meters per second
at an altitude of about a kilometer off
the surface of mars
here in safety bravo we have
completed our terrain relative
navigation current speed is about
30 meters per second altitude about 300
meters
off the surface of mars
we have started our constant velocity
accordion which means we are
conducting the sky crane about to
conduct the flyclean maneuver
we've lost direct to earth to tones
as expected as expected sky cream
maneuver has started
about 20 meters off the surface
we're getting signals from mro
uhf is good
touchdown confirmed
[Applause]
at this point the descending stage has
flown away to save shifts since
perseverance is continuing to transmit
direct through marsupial orbiter to
earth
[Applause]
oh my god oh
still getting telemetry from the lander
all right
all right all stations uh we got it
we're gonna wait for the images wow
this is so exciting the team is beside
themselves it's
it's it's so surreal stay tuned we might
get some pictures
so much has been riding on this
you know yeah we just heard the news
that
perseverance is alive on the surface of
mars
it's not uh it's not
we have seen the completion of edl 3000
copy activity that is as expected
signal from the lander
we have just heard the news that
perseverance is alive
on the surface of mars congrats so
scenes of jubilation there
in pasadena in california commission
control
for nasa as nasa's mars rover the
perseverance
the most advanced robotic astrobiology
lab ever flown to another planet
executed an audacious landing on the red
planet
marking the end of its seven month and
293 mile
journey the reaction of our guests
watching that thomas moore as well as
libby jackson
manager of the human exploration program
at the uk space
agency and dr becky smithhurst an
astrophysicist
at the university of oxford i could see
your faces beaming
as we saw those pictures thomas more
talk us through
how significant a moment this is oh it's
huge and this is the most technically
advanced rover that has ever been sent
to mars
uh it also has uh for the first time a
helicopter that will attempt the first
powered flight
over another planet so that's a real
wright brothers moment
uh on on mars um all these are
significant because they're all pointing
in the same direction we're trying to
find
evidence of ancient life in one
particular region this
uh crater the jezreel crater which is 28
miles wide that the
rover has landed in and it will explore
the sediments there
because it once was an enormous lake fed
by a river there is a delta there with
deposits that could
act as fly paper uh for these organic
signals of of ancient life it's highly
unlikely there's any life there now
because it is a
desolate sterile planet but once upon a
time it had a climate which is very much
like earth's
uh and and that's gone but the the
evidence of life may
remain and that would be a huge moment
for for humankind
well yes so much to explore
so much possibility here but dr becky
smethus first of all just a comment
on that extraordinary descent
by the mars rover there i mean the
descent was described as seven minutes
of terror before of this by
nasa weren't they i mean why was it so
potentially
perilous and uh how tense a moment was
it for you watching it
it was incredibly tense for me watching
it because i kind of know what they're
going through
you know the seven minutes of terror
really does describe just the amount of
incredible heat that the rover has to
um overcome falling through the
atmosphere as well its parachute has to
release at the right time
it then has to correct its own course to
land in the right place in the crater
and avoid all of the hazards of
cliff edges and boulders that are in the
way as well we're seeing a lovely
picture there that's come back from from
the surface that the rover sent back
which is great to see
and so it really is seven minutes of
terror because this is not something
that you can test
at all in earth's atmosphere you know
the first time it gets tested is when
it's falling through
the atmosphere and so someone has to
code up all of those instructions and
those of these things to say if this
happens do this
instead that all has to be coded into a
computer you know i
code every day in my job as an
astrophysicist studying black holes and
i can tell you my code crashes every
single day as well and something goes
wrong
so i did not envy them you know sat in
the control room
literally watching as as their
instructions are you know interpreted by
a computer and
anything could go wrong at any point and
there's nothing you can do about it
because
you know by the time the signal gets
back to you it's already probably
uh on the surface as we've heard it did
actually come down successfully so
i was absolutely relieved when that uh
the call came through to say telemetry
received which essentially meant signal
received
from the rover and it's doing all good a
lot of fist-bumping going on there in
the control
center as well you can see that the
relief and the joy
there too can't you uh libby jackson
we're already getting pictures aren't we
back i know that there's an 11 minute
delay i think in the signal just because
mars is so far away but
give us an idea of what happens next to
perseverance
well the science team the people in
mission control they are back hard at
work
we've got uk scientists who are going to
help plan
where this rover is going to go uh which
rocks it's going to pick up and they're
starting work at four o'clock in the
morning
um so it's right on to work we've got
about 30 martian days 30 souls of check
out to make sure that the rover is all
in one piece
um to make it move to check the wheels
are there check out all of his
instruments and then it will get to work
collecting those rocks
and this is just so wonderful because we
have such a strong
set of scientists and engineers here in
the uk
building the instruments that are on
mars rovers building
mars rovers and this just kicks off the
start of our whole series of work that's
going to happen here in the uk over the
coming years
um and it also just means that we've got
a mission
and it's go we're going to see those
samples and hopefully returned back to
earth
early in the next decade and the uk is
playing a huge part in that
very exciting stuff although quite a
weight of course which is tantalizing
thomas i think we do have another
picture that has already been fed back
from the surface of mars while we look
at that
tell us about the wider significance of
a mission like this i mean it's a
question that as
people have asked for generations and
generations is there life on another
planet i mean it's
it's a huge uh scientific question but
also
it has wider philosophical meaning for
so many people too
for sure and i mean science fiction came
up with this idea of you know little
green men on mars and of course life on
on mars was
never anything like that we're talking
about microorganisms here microscopic
life that evolved at a very early stage
but never really got going uh because
the conditions are marched mars abruptly
changed
but the fact that if if there is life
there
ancient life then for it to have evolved
on on two planets
uh together independently in the same
solar system
that really does increase the odds that
there will still be life
elsewhere uh in the galaxy in in the
universe
perhaps multiple times and that some of
that life may well be intelligent
and i think that really does show that
we may not be alone
and that that is a it is an interesting
existential question but that this
mission could help
answer well thomas thank you very much
indeed for guiding us
through and of course thanks to libby
jackson manager
of the human exploration program at the
uk space agency
and dr becky smethus an astrophysicist
at the university of oxford guiding us
through that extraordinary mission
uh seeing a nasa rover landing on mars
in its
epic quest to bring back rocks that
could help answer whether life ever
existed
there on the red planet thanks all